okay welcome to the uh lab for chapter
11 on Survival
analysis um in this lab we study um
outcomes which are times to event so for
example for cancer patients the the
event is typically death from cancer um
and uh but for other events for example
we have a publication data set and the
time the event there is is when it was
when the document is actually published
and so there specialized methods for for
modeling such data and Jonathan's going
to lead us off on this lab okay thanks
Trevor yes so um as Trevor mentioned
it's what the specialized methods are
really um you know slightly different
loss function um so it's it's we're
going to see methods that look like
regression methods that's the Cox
proportional hazards model but it's not
a squared error loss and it's not a
classification loss it's a special loss
for for uh time data and what's when
something that's interesting with these
kinds of data is because you track
people or or events or observations and
some of them don't reach the event and
or they leave the study early so they
get censored so sensoring is something
that one has to deal with with these
kinds of data yes and this is baked into
the loss as you would have seen in the
in the
chapter okay so uh you know as usual for
for a lab we start off with our our
Imports of sort of known packages um and
these should be pretty familiar by now
there are some specific packages for um
for survival analysis that we'll use and
that's in this lifelines package uh so
the the topics we're going to talk about
today are fitting the Kaplan Meer curves
and fitting Cox's proportional hazards
model as well as some uh test statistics
um the log rang test uh you would have
seen in in the chapter and we'll also uh
mention a multivariate log rank test in
the the call center data we simulate
time so we wrote a little utility
function here if you specify the hazard
function and covariates how to draw a
time from that
distribution okay so our first uh data
set is the the brain cancer data set um
and we're going to start off by fitting
uh some simple K Meer curves to the data
so there are several um you know
features in here uh for each patient uh
um one of them is the the diagnosis and
I think that's the cancer type um
there's the the subject sex um there's
this Ki is called the carnovsky index a
measure developed by physicians to to to
measure this somehow the severity of the
tumor ggv is tumor volume um and then
there's these key variables here uh
status and time and these are the
variables that over and over again
you'll see in survival analysis time is
the time recorded for that subject and
status this is that censoring variable
that Trevor mentioned so if an event uh
occurs typically status will be one so
if in this study we have a patient and
they actually if this if the outcome is
death the patient died then their status
would be one but if they were still
alive at the end of the study well then
their status would be zero but we would
have known they survived at least to the
time this time recorded uh in the
experiment okay um so there 88 patients
here and let's start off by
um uh looking at a simple Klan Meer
curve okay so the cap Meer curve uh the
it looks something somewhat like um uh a
psych learn estimator and that you first
instantiate it and then you call uh fit
on it um it's uh you know I I I'd have
to we'd have to look at the package to
actually know if it is a psych learn
estimator the Cox proportional hazards
model is much closer to a pyit learn
estimator the K Meer curve is really
just an estimate of the um the survival
function or in the distribution function
of the time data and it takes into takes
two arguments one is the the outcome y
um and the other is the the status
outcome and actually just looking at the
signature I can tell it's not a psych
learn estimator because for those this
would be a set of features the first
argument that would be X and this would
be why but that's not how the signature
is okay so it has a plot method um and
we're going to take a look at it okay so
this is what the Klan Meyer curve looks
like and it plots here this is
a uh the survival function s of T and
this is the probability or this is the
estimated probability that a time is
bigger than
T okay and that's actually very thin
pencil I'll have to fix fix that so
that's one minus the distribution
function yes let's put that in there you
can make the things pin thicker Jonathan
yes let's see how that is and that's
well slightly thicker one minus the
distribution function f of T yeah okay
and what do we see here um we get a a
point estimate of the of the survival
function and we have error bars here and
one thing we note is that as we get to
larger and larger times uh we get wider
and wider error bars and that's because
well the way this estimate is produced
it's sort of in effect looking at
something like the the number of people
who have survived past 50 here roughly
and uses that to compute the variance
estimate but there are just fewer who
survive to 50 then who survived to 10
okay um so often we'll have some uh
categorical variable and that that might
be of interest uh and we'd like to
compare survival between the the two
different levels of the category so here
we're going to do a sort of um
stratified plot or plot of the of the K
Meer curve in both in within both sexes
for this data we don't have any reason
to believe that sex is is an important
uh predictor but we're just showing you
how to use a a you know a predictor to
produce you know a plot to compare the
two estimates it looks pretty important
uh because it looks like uh males die
much more quickly than than females yes
on this data okay yeah yes so
so it may be important here but I just I
don't know I I don't know enough about
the source of this data to know whether
this was an interesting category but
that's a good observation though I guess
if we should note probably that the
error bars are a little bit overlapping
but there's looks like there might be
some difference maybe a bigger sample
size would would would show elucidate
this okay so all we're doing here is
we're just using this uh group bu of the
data frame and that gives us um individ
idual data frames that we can use um to
fit a capit Meer curve and we're just
plotting
those okay one thing I've done here is
I've sort of I've collected uh the data
frame here um in this dictionary byx
because we're going to use that uh in a
in a few celles here but this isn't used
in making this plot just as we're
breaking the data into the two groups
I'm going to collect this because we're
going to do a test to see whether
there's a difference in survival between
um male and female that'll that will
settle
it yes let's let's see what the P value
is okay so for a categorical variable
with two levels uh you know the a common
test used to to test whether there's a
difference in survival is the log rank
test um and the log rank test basically
takes you know the information needed to
fit two cap M survival curves and that
is for the uh one group say the male it
takes the time and the status and the
other group the female it takes its time
and its status and it gives you some
overall test to test whether there's any
difference in survival it's not specific
at any particular time but somehow
averaged over all of the time points and
the way this test looks uh the way the
test is constructed which you might have
read about um in the chapter is that it
sort of looks at Compares survival makes
a little 2 by two survival at every time
point and sort of pools these in some
fashion
okay so the log rank test uh these are
the
results oh good the P value is 22% okay
so we I'm saying good for the males yes
yeah iess I guess we're okay here uh so
if this P value was really small that
would be you know strong evidence of a
difference between survival and male and
female it doesn't seem to be in the not
that you'd want any of these cancers but
no yeah yeah okay so you know that if we
have one category variable the log rang
test can be used to to compare two
groups but often we have other
covariates um and for that we need some
kind of regression model that's this uh
proportional Hazard model is the
sort of default regression model for
time to event data uh and it's fit a lot
like um our other models except the
response again is uh this um there's an
event time and an event status okay so
let's take in this first model we just
look at the six the same one we used
with the captain Meer test that's right
this is just a simple model but later
we'll have other features um okay and
and look at and notice the P value is
exactly the same as in the cap 23 H
that's interesting I wonder if that's
related actually it's this is this is a
you know a well-known fact when you have
a a Cox regression model with a single
categorical binary categorical variable
um the uh the the the test uh actually
this is probably this is the wall test
it may not be exactly the same one I
think the score it's called the score
test exactly agrees with the log rank
test but the wall test the score test
and the likelihood ratio test you would
learn in some other class are often very
similar um we're not going to dwell on
those here but it's we're not surprised
that this is 0 23 um so you can think of
uh this Cox regression model that's
somehow a generalization of the log rank
test U if you were to test for
we might include something like the
carnovsky index and there would still be
a P value for sex allowing for the
effect of the the carosi index that
would be different than the log rank
test uh but um so in that in that sense
the Cox model kind of generalizes the
log rank test okay let's just take a
quick look at how this is fit we make a
design matrix it's a regression model so
we use our model spec that we've uh done
before and so when we call um call the
fit function on the the Cox proportional
Hazard model object we give it a data
frame and we have to indicate here two
columns um this is these are the two
variables that specify the outcome right
this is the the time variable and this
is whether the the observation is
censored or not so this looks like a
psyit learn estimator except psyit learn
estimator would just have X and Y this
again has a little argument that's
because we need two columns to specify
the response but other than that it
looks kind of
similar
okay so we can also actually directly
compute the log lik ratio test and
that's another test similar to the score
test and similar to that wall test and
its P value is also 0. 23 that's related
to the fact that the score the
likelihood in the wall test are often
kind of similar the score test and the
log rank exactly the same say so there
yeah yes yes this one is not the score
test this is the that's what I meant
yeah yeah the score test is the cut yes
right yes so you know this class is not
all about these different kinds of tests
but it's you know you're you will
hopefully move on to do some more
statistics and seeing some of these
facts is helpful and this is just a
numerical example of
that okay so we're going to fit you know
a more complicated regression model just
because you know there might be other um
well there are other features other
besides just the sex of the patient that
are likely important for survival and
we'd like to understand how they affect
survival so turns out that some of the
um some of the one of the diagnosis
values is missing so we have an
incomplete data set we're going to
remove that with the drop na a method uh
and then we're going to you know make a
design Matrix as we've done for
regression before and then the rest of
this uh is similar to this is just the
same as the cell above except now we
instead of having just sex we have all
these other variables and you can see
these this diagnosis group this is the
the um
the type of cancer um and you can
compare um so so let's just pause for a
second to think about what the sign of
these coefficients mean so the way the
coefficients should be interpreted are
you know um well the simplest let's just
do write out what a what the hazard rate
looks like for a if I just had a single
predictor very you know roughly speaking
the hazard rate for let's make a bigger
pencil
how do oh I guess I can do that is that
right yes Hazard rate T and X is
something like
um uh some baseline Hazard right uh and
e to the beta x x that's very poor
handwriting but but that's not just
because I'm writing on a tablet I have
poor handwriting so um so and what is
this Hazard rate this is sort of some
instantaneous measurement of how quickly
you're going to fail so if uh beta x x
is positive that means you're more
likely to fail at that time whether if
it's negative you're less likely to fail
so if we have a negative coefficient
like this Koski index here Ki has a
negative coefficient that means if I
have a high positive value of Koski
index then the beta corresponding to
that will be negative and so all other
things being equal having a higher Koski
index is sort of associated with longer
survival
um okay so you can use that we similarly
we can see that maybe men and geoma um
is has perhaps longer survival than uh
Goma
here
okay so we have these different uh
categories of um diagnosis different
cancer types we might want to now make
something like the Kaplan Meyer plot
that summarizes the survival curve for
Within These each of these groups but of
course within each group all the other
features are varying right there's going
to be men and women in every diagnosis
group there's going to be uh people of
different age people of different Koski
index so to plot a survival curve we
have to kind of pick a typical value and
so we're going to pick we write this
little function here that's going to
Define pick a typical value for each of
the features having fixed that then we
can change the diagnosis and for every
different diagnosis we'll get different
survival curves so that's what these two
cells are doing
um
and we can look let's just take a look
at the uh the plotted survival
curves so for each of the four diagnosis
there's a typical value for all the
other all the other variables and this
is just
um well the Cox model it specifies a
model for this thing we called the
hazard rate which is this instantaneous
rate of failure and from the hazard rate
you can get the survival curve um so
this just plots the estimate of the
survival curve for four different sets
of covariates the only difference
between these is just what type of
diagnosis if we changed the sex or the
carosi index all four curves would move
in unison they wouldn't look all the
same but this gives some idea about you
know relative
differences so we see that um the uh you
know I mentioned earlier that men and
geoma had a more negative coefficient so
it might be associated with
um long survival and we see that at the
end of the study 75% rough or 70% are
are survived compared to um the Goma and
uh and that HG Goma it looks very very
severe looks really aggressive yeah
yeah